there are people that are not trusting
the process with my new business venture
which kind of is upsetting me many
people know that I'm a comedian that's
we've kind of established that already
but what people don't know is that's not
my real my real passion my real passion
has always been jewelry and I've seen
the look on someone's face when you give
them something that is special and
unique and to me what that is is a
perfectly set stone perfectly set stone
it could be topaz could be one of the
other ones and jewelry has been in my
passion now a lot of people are like
they're not did we have a mail-order
jewelry business called Jules buy
podcaster Tim Dylan a lot of people have
given us a lot of money under now
getting angry at us because the jewels
haven't showed up but they're home for
them to sell now this is the type of
amateur [ __ ] that I expect from some
of these people this is amateur hour
okay number one you you don't need the
physical jewels to sell you can get out
there and you're selling a lifestyle
you're selling an idea you're selling an
identity so you're gonna get the jewels
they're coming but I fear for many of
you because the complaints are so
unnecessary and I just feel like a lot
of you aren't taking it seriously you
have one job when you sell jewels my
podcaster Tim Dunn - you have to
convince people that they are not happy
because they don't have the right
jewelry and you also have to convince
them that they need to sell jewelry for
me and you and this whole com trying to
start a company here and a lot of people
don't take me seriously I'm trying to
start a goddamn a company in operation I
just feel like a lot of you are
ungrateful because many of you have no
idea how to be an entrepreneur and I am
a businessman that's what I've been
since I'm a little baby boy I've been a
business boy forever in my whole life
all of my existence has been business
crunching numbers chopping the onions
making it work fit in a square peg no
around whatever the point is I don't
need your [ __ ] ungrateful mouth all
the kid is in here the drool kits not
here improvise you stupid [ __ ] figure
it out it's gonna get there it's on its
[ __ ] way you're gonna get it
also we're coming up with the sales
strategy because I realize that many of
you need much more help than I'd
anticipated which is okay I want to give
you that help but many of you are not
salespeople you're not closer so I can
hear it in your voices I can hear it in
your emails that are very and that are
rage-filled when you send me an email
and you're like I spent all this money I
didn't I haven't been given any guidance
or any how but I don't even have the
jewels where are the jewels I'm telling
everyone I'm selling jewelry for you I
can't even do it you know all I hear is
failure and I don't know is that who you
are is that who you want to be that's
not who I want to be that's not what I
am so we're doing a seminar in and then
Arizona Hilton or Marriott we're gonna
see and it's gonna be three days I just
give me a three day intensive sales
training seminar we're gonna train you
on the product you got to get trained on
the product then you got to get trained
on the strategy and then once you have
the product and the strategy you good to
[ __ ] go okay product plus strategy
sales strategy okay now I'm gonna show
you this is an example and again you're
not gonna beat the level I'm at for a
very long time maybe never but if you
listen to me I've invited Ben to lunch
Bennis someone I have not seen in a very
long time I've invited him to launch by
messaging him on Facebook we do a lot of
our ads on Facebook stay away from
Twitter stay away from Instagram stay
away from god forbid tick tock
stay on Facebook what I like about
Facebook is it Zuckerberg they're not
crate they're not trying to verify
everything on there they're just letting
it fly which i think is very important
for a small business that she's starting
so I messaged Ben and I want to get
lunch with him and I don't bring up
tools up by podcaster Tim Dylan in the
message I just reconnect with him
authentically and he agrees to have
lunch with me at the local diner now
we've done some of our bullshitting and
now it's the time when I'm going to
pouch
the word is pounce like a puma would
like a big cat if you ever seen a big
cat [ __ ] something up with his paw
that's what we're doing but we're
helping people do you understand that
I'm helping him but because he is so
lost I need to to paw him like a large
cat would to help him now see this is
the time when I'm going to do it
ha this lunch has been very good I've
enjoyed it it was great yeah it's very
so good it's very good I enjoyed I like
rye bread me too it's it's wonderful so
nice to see you I haven't seen you since
high school
how's things it's pretty good you know I
think could be better though not gonna
lie well let me tell you a story do you
want to hear a story you have time for a
story I'd love to hear one I have
nothing to do when I was a young child I
became obsessed with jewelry I would
steal it I would wear it and I would
sell it and even though looking back on
that now that seems immoral mm-hmm what
it did was give me a real understanding
of the market the market for jewels I
have an opportunity for you I have a
company right now that I haven't told
anybody about because I'm still trying
to decide who's worthy about knowing
about it
it's called joules by podcaster Tim
Dylan now I see your face and you're
surprised in you're shocked and I think
maybe feel a little lucky do you feel
you feel you feel a little lucky
you're not wrong to be lucky what I want
you to do is I want you to go into your
community I want you to go to your
family your friends people who trust you
people who you built rapport with over
your entire life and sell them jewelry
that I have provided for you to sell
them I get my jewelry from the best
jeweler I won't tell you where okay but
have you seen the movie uncut gems yeah
him there's nothing like the look on
someone's face when you when you marry
them to it perfectly set stone many
people aren't happy in their life
they're fat and they're on heroin and
the reason that this is the case is
because God is dead and the country is
[ __ ] now
even though it's kind of good it's still
[ __ ] but one thing that always glitters
brightly is a jewel and everybody wants
it
that's why do you do you remember Snow
White in the Seven Dwarfs
yeah what were the dwarfs doing they
were mining for little jewels that is
the oldest story in America Snow White
in the Seven Dwarfs
really yes so in the beginning they were
jewels there will always be jewels and
when you you have to make people
understand how lucky they are to be in
the unique position of being sold
jewelry over the phone or in person at
their house because you say you could
take a trip mrs. Miller when I go into a
sale I go
hello mrs. Miller you could go anywhere
and buy jewelry but you're not buying it
from a trusted name and you're not
buying it from somebody that has a
passion so what are you really doing
you're being stupid
and if you're stupid you're going to
but I don't fail I win because I'm not
stupid I'm smart my jewels are bright
they shine
remember the rap song shine like the
diamond shine bright like a diamond
shine bright like a diamond that's not
the way it goes but I like the way I'm
doing a little better shine bright like
a diamond the best thing about d-tools
is I'm not only selling them to you I'm
selling them to you so that you can sell
them to other people so you're trying to
help me I want to help you I don't want
to help you create a revenue stream I
don't want you to have to get up to work
a nine-to-five job like some dumb Pig
I want you to be able to create your own
business and your own opportunities I
want you to have multiple revenue
streams I want you to have a sales
strategy that works for you I want you
to put your tentacles into the community
and then choke people very softly so
that they understand that jewels buy
podcaster Tim Dylan is the [ __ ] thing
that is gonna be the thing that's gonna
happen